[Applaudissements]
donc c'est une fourchette et vous dites
bon ce type là il s'est gouré il est
distrait il devait prendre la zapette là
et puis il a pris la fourchette au
dernier moment qu'est ce que c'est que
ce truc en fait non je me suis pas gouré
vous verrez pourquoi j'ai une fourchette
et je suis pas si distraits que ça en
parlant distraction vous souvenez du
film le distrait ça vous dit quelque
chose
pierre richard lui il aurait il aurait
échangé la zapette contre la fourchette
donc pas moi par contre je suis
effectivement je suis venu vous parler
d'attention et plus précisément je suis
venu vous parler d'éducation d'attention
et plus précisément encore je parle je
suis venu vous parler d'un projet un
programme d'éducation d'attention qui
s'appelle atoll à théo est le ca vient
d'apprendre la tension à l'école et
c'est un programme qui est destiné
effectivement à prendre la tension à
l'école opéti et l'avantagé que c'est
gratuit c'est bien et encore ça existe
encore service public
je suis payée par l'inserm voilà je payé
par l'état a été financé par l'agencé
nationale pour la recherche encore
l'état c'est gratuit et c'est pas vous
le produit savez ça existe encore donc
éducation de l'attention à l'école lever
à main ceux qui ceux qui vont lever la
main en fait c'est rien à voir mais
j'avais tellement envie de la faire ça
m'est venue tout à l'heure je fis il
faut que je la fasse quoi en plus fait
la fin lever la main ceux qui ont déjà
eu un court d'attention à l'école un
vrai cours quoi d'accord même pas un don
qui sait exactement ce que je vois ce
que je m'attendais ben moi non plus j'ai
pas eu de cours de l'attention sur la
tension et c'est un peu étrange parce
qu'en fait qu'on peut traverser son
système scolaire en se faisant
régulièrement engueuler trop distrait ça
arrive ça sur les butins c'est comme ça
qu'on entend parler d'attention à
l'école mais sans qu'on nous explique
jamais ce que c'est que la tension et
comment il faut faire pour être attentif
je comprends qu'on puisse se faire
engueuler parce qu'on a fait une erreur
dans une dictée parce qu'on est censé
avoir appris l'orthographe les
déclinaisons et autres tables de
multiplication l'essentiel est d'avoir
appris donc quand on fait une erreur ok
c'est normal mais la tension nous
apprend jamais à faire attention donc
pourquoi est ce qu'on nous
pourquoi est-ce qu'on sera engueuler
parce qu'on n'est pas attentif et ben
donc moi je pense qu'il faut absolument
un programme d'éducation de la tension
est particulièrement crucial j'ai essayé
de vous en convaincre
et pourquoi parce que l'attention
figurez-vous c'est ce qui détermine à
chaque instant ce que vous avez dans
l'esprit ce que vous entendez ce que
vous voyez ce que vous pensez est ce que
vous apprenez tous assez déterminé par
la tension et la fourchette elle est là
parce que la tension ça va être une
sorte de chf fourchette mental qui va
prendre des petites choses et vous allez
vous mettre dans la tête avec fap à la
fourchette mais les choses que vous
prenez avec votre fourchette mentale en
parlant d'attention qui s'intéressent à
son alimentation ou à celle de ses
enfants
normalement j'ai plus demain penser que
c'est important
vous avez raison parce que s'intéresser
à son alimentation c'est s'intéresser à
ce qui rentre dans notre corps est donc
ce qui nous constitue et bien
s'intéresser à la tension c'est tout
aussi important parce que c'est
s'intéresser à ce qui rend dans notre
tête et qui nous constitue donc avoir la
maîtrise de son attention c'est avoir la
maîtrise de ce qu'on pourrait appeler
l'alimentation mental son alimentation
mentalement j'ai pire j'ai samantha
linda menthe alimentation c'est vraiment
alimentation j'y reviendrai donc éduquer
la menthe alimentation éduqués et
prendre la maîtrise retrouver la
maîtrise de samantha limitation
curieusement en fait on s'intéresse
beaucoup plus à ce qu'on met dans sa
bouche d'ailleurs notamment en france
qu'est ce qu'on met dans sa tête par
exemple prenez quelqu'un qui a gagné une
vidéo et qui est en train de faire des
sms en même temps peut pas dire ça
choque grand monde parce que ça se
produit tout le temps par contre si vous
voyez quelqu'un qui au restaurant ou
même chez vous prend un bol mais son
entrée mais son dessert appuie dessus
pour tout mélanger et ensuite boîte ou
là ça fait bizarre
pourtant c'est exactement la même chose
en fait quand on y réfléchit
donc voilà donc éduquer l'attention
c'est quoi c'est apprendre aux gens à
contrôler ce qu'ils mettent dans leur
tête avec leurs fourchettes mental et
c'est pas si facile parce que si vite
fait de se laisser un petit peu
manipulée par d'autres et laisser
d'autres destinés à notre place de ce
qu'on a dans la tête
vous voyez par exemple je prends un
petit rat imaginer un râle à un gros rat
là bas si je veux je peux lui faire
manger du poison c'est pas très
difficile on le sait tous tout ce que
j'ai à faire c'est à planquer le poison
dans des petites boulettes de nourriture
hyper appétissantes pour lui là je sais
que le rav à manger le poison c'est
comme ça que ça marche et j'utilise un
système système de neurones dans son
cerveau qui s'appelle circuit de
récompense et qui va le mettre en
recherche systématiquement de ski tout
de tout ce qui peut lui apporter une
sorte de sentiment de gratification
immédiate faire quelque chose d'agréable
là j'ai une vraie faille de sécurité
dans son cerveau que je peux utiliser
pour faire entrer ce que je veux dans
son corps un peu selon le principe du
cheval de troie c'est vraiment un
principe du cheval de troie ben vous et
moi on est des rats évoluer finalement
désolé de vous lire évolué j'ai dit
évolué et donc on a un circuit la
récompense tous pareils et ce circuit la
récompense il va être sensible non
seulement la nourriture mais également
au mans aliments et il va être
constamment être là pour essayer
d'attirer de dévier notre comportement
est d'attirer notre action notre
attention sur certains trucs qui ont ce
petit côté un petit peu excitant donc si
votre petit dernier ce bourg de bonbons
circulent la récompense si vous avez un
ado à la maison qui sans fil des séries
au fond de son lit les unes après les
autres circuits la récompense c'est que
la fia non
c'est pas qu'il est foncièrement nefa ce
circuit de la récompense parce que c'est
le même circuit qui va permettre de
faire boire aux petits sons doliprane
vous allez mettre un succulent si on
voulait le sucré à mort et puis vous
mettez du doliprane dedans et il va le
boire et puis par ailleurs c'est lui qui
nous rend furieux enfin il a plein de
bons aspects c'est surtout la récompense
mais problème c'est qu'on sait pas
tellement s'en serviront s'est passé
avec deux circuits la récompense est
donc il ouvre cette porte qui permet
assez facilement de rentrer dans le
cerveau de quelqu'un
imaginez qu la la j'ai envie de capter
votre attention je me mets mon bandeau
là comme un cambrioleur j'essayais
d'aller prendre le petit trésor
donc comment je vais me prendre eh ben
je vais hacker votre système
attentionnel tout simplement en
exploitant les failles de sécurité donc
je vais vous proposer votre votre mental
iman préféré celui qui va le plus active
et vous de circuit de récompense
comment je vais faire je vous montrais
des petits trucs rigolos des trucs
flashy des petits chatons je sais pas
des trucs qui bougent des jeux parlait
de vous je vous parlait également de vos
proches
enfin tout ça ça va avoir tendance à
stimuler vos circuits la récompense est
là bas vous allez gober tout ce que je
vous donne je vais faire en sortant que
ces petits menthe aliments je vais place
de façon à ce que vous avez quasiment
rien à faire pour les avoir tout de
suite ils sont là vous prenez votre
petite fourchette mental ils sont
immédiatement sous la main et puis je
remette partout je leur mette dans votre
poche je remette à côté de vos cris
lui-même en maître sur le trottoir comme
ça je suis sûr que vous les avez
s'aimantent aliments souvenez vous les
petits drames tira avec ses boulettes de
poison en principe ça marche
sauf si vous avez fait suivi un
programme qui vous apprend ces failles
de sécurité dans votre système
attentionnel qui vous apprend à résoudre
à les résoudre donc c'est à dire en gros
si vous avez suivi une éducation de la
tension mais j'ai pas grand chose à
craindre parce que la tension s'est pas
prendre
non ce que j'ai un crâne en fait je m'en
fous je me méfie c'est que je suis pas
le seul à voir capter votre attention ce
que n'importe qui qui a quelque chose à
vous vendre va vouloir que vous le
remarquez donc il va avoir besoin de
votre attention impérativement et c'est
pour ça que la tension vous savez en
parler avant de l'or noir choix que
celle pétrole l'or bleu ces lots lors
jaune basse et leur bail alors invisible
en fait lors invisible ce serait la
tension c'est vraiment la ressource la
plus convoitée à l'heure actuelle et
provenant pour encore longtemps
donc je me retrouve là dans une sorte de
course aux armements parce que par
rapport aux petits copains qui veulent
aussi votre attention moi il va falloir
que je sois plus imaginatifs et surtout
il va falloir que une fois que j'étais
votre attention je fasse tout pour la
garder
donc si je vous montre des vidéos bah je
vais vous montrer une autre vidéo juste
après et puis non juste après et puis je
vous l'a jamais si je vous fais lire un
truc longues pages pages n'arrête pas la
page elle continue comme ça tout le
temps tout le temps vous êtes dedans ça
vous dit quelque chose je crois qu'on a
parlé tout à l'heure
ok et puis si j'ai assez d'argent
je vais payer des ingénieurs et c'est
l'ingénieur je voulais faire un petit
peu bosser sur des algorithmes dia qui
j'ai appris son temps libre sur ce lip
n'importe qui peut les récupérer pour
essayer de décoder à partir de votre
comportement de tout ce que vous faites
ce qui est susceptible à un moment donné
de vous intéresser d'attirer votre
attention
alors vos chers petits enfants le petit
théo la petite lisa le petit moral je
sais pas quoi ben quand il se comporte
face à un écran ils ont un comportement
qui est assez stéréotypique qui pas
toujours pas toujours bien réfléchi et
ce comportement s'est pas taire 10e des
codes et ils s'utilisent oui je veux en
venir
donc à coup on arrive on peut arriver à
une situation où votre petit théo petite
lisa tim brown bat finalement ils se
voient proposer à longueur de journée
par le biais d'écrans leur mentent
aliments favoris ceux qui vont plus
stimuler leur circuit de la récompense à
haute dose et le jour vous essayer de
leur donner quelque chose d'autre que
leur bonbon manteau l'afrique mental par
exemple un livre qui demande un petit
peu d'efforts qui demande deux de se
plonger dedans pour commencer à
ressentir un sentiment de plaisir
quelque chose qui n'est pas
immédiatement gratifiant et ben il vous
faut leur cracher à la gueule en tant
que chercheur en neuroscience cognitive
c'est mon boulot là je me suis dit que
c'était un peu ma responsabilité
d'essayer d'engager une sorte de
mouvement de rébellion contre ça ça veut
dire quoi
bah ça veut dire éduquer l'attention par
le biais de ce projet atoll le projet
atoll comment ça marche en fait c'est un
truc qui simplement bas va montrer aux
gamins les manettes qu'ils peuvent
utiliser pour reprendre le contrôle de
leur attention ce qui va dans leur tête
mais surtout le projet atoll va chercher
à leur faire goûter le plaisir d'une
attention stable continue et essayer de
leur faire découvrir la joie intense
qu'on peut ressentir quand on est
complètement dans ce qu'on fait c'est un
projet qui est menée par les enseignants
ces low tech qui a rien au bout de
ficelle il ya un qui se branchent ya
rien d'électronique c'est les
enseignants qui entre qui enseigne la
tension dans les classes et ce qui veut
dire que les attendait les enseignants
eux mêmes se sont formés à la tension
est donc qu'ils ont changé leur point de
vue sur la tension est donc au lieu de
gueuler les gamins en dix ans n'est pas
attentif c'est pas bien etc
ils vont se poser avec lui ils vont
essayer de comprendre avec lui parce
qu'il s'est passé alors dans le détail
j'ai bien rire d'un petit copain
je montrerai pourquoi en fait là bas
c'est quand même d'apprendre des jeux
aux gamins à agir avec une intention
claire en définissant très précisément
ce à quoi ils doivent se connecter avec
leur attention et comment y réagir
et puis ensuite figurez-vous que
pourquoi il abat papa est bien parce que
se concentrer c'est un peu faire comme
barbe à papa
oui il pleut barbe à papa il va se
transformer en abris il ya un mur à
passer et barbe à papa il va se
transforme en escalier ces pratiques se
concentrer c'est un peu transformé son
cerveau pour l'adapter à un besoin
précis par exemple la imaginons que je
cherche quelqu'un avec une écharpe rouge
eh ben je vais transformer légèrement
mon cerveau pour me rendre plus sensible
à ce qui est rouge et je vais trouver la
personne qui à l'écharpé rouge
donc ça on va l'expliquer au ghana on va
leur expliquer à faire ces petits
réglages et surtout on va voir leur
expliquer que c'est une mauvaise idée
d'essayer d'être à la fois un escalier
et un abribus
alors la petite lisa tout à l'heure en
classe on va faire monter sur une poutre
et puis sur la poutre comme ça elle va
découvrir que l'attention c'est une
question d'équilibré
et puis on va lui donner des bottes
d'emploi pour se concentre avec ce soit
sur la lecture d'un livre où elle pourra
prendre une poésie et puis on va lui
faire prendre conscience de ces failles
de sécurité dont je parlais tout à
l'heure comme ça et se laissera plus
piéger et puis on va lui apprendre comme
ça à garder un cap est utilisé en fait
les vents et les courants qui poussent
sur son attention bas pour aller là où
elle veut je pourrais vous parler de
l'attention pendant encore trois heures
mais je suis surtout venu vous dire que
cette vaste communauté qui est en train
de se former pour protéger la tension et
qu'une révolte joyeuse est engagé merci
[Applaudissements]